good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy Tuesday
arguably the worst day of the week hey
Jax how you doing I'm doing okay I've
caught whatever rolled had so I'm now
16. you hate to see it but you hate to
see it you know doing my best I'm so
glad that we recently bought full body
heating pads they're like heating pads
that you wear we'll post the link at
like not to be like so rub it in your
face about our new heating pads
um not to Brad not to brag and I hadn't
busted it out yet because the other
bruise heating pad sufficed for the both
of us but I've been wearing my new
heating pad and it's definitely a small
bright spot
in the sickness 100
um heating pads like truly change and
save lives so I'm so glad that we
invested in ourselves yeah definitely I
know I left both my heating pads like on
my bed and I just like no Brew is in the
bed cuddled up in multiple heating pads
like so jealous living the life I want
to live
I um
it's always been like obvi fairly clear
like I'm the number one Auntie to rolled
but I think you know during this time
while he's been sick I have started to
feel like sympathy pains as well like I
have like a sore back I have a little
tickle in my throat yep I am really
um and I need to take care of myself
because I have toured this weekend
tickets available at girls no job.com
tour
um but honestly I wouldn't have it any
other way because if rolled suffers we
all suffer we all suffer of course now
he's semi on the mend and the red and
the rest of us are down and out but I
mean I just need to know how long this
is gonna last for like that's so classic
rolls is it the day is it three days
like I just I need to know I need to
plan
that's the thing about being a mom that
I've like learned from Olivia especially
with Kayla now like being a social girly
going to like different camp and classes
and things
um kids are literally disgusting like
yeah they are cesspools of germs
bacteria and like illnesses and justice
for the teachers yeah those teachers
have immune systems
of Steel like bull Steel
yeah because Kayla it's every other day
with her you know
yeah that's kids man
that's his
and I just assume they wasn't gonna get
whatever he had because I have a
stronger immune system like having 30
years of immunity
um you know it was just laying dormant
waiting laying door waiting until like
he started to feel better so that like
we could double the length of the
illness
right like it never ran and then I'm
sure in a few days Zach will be like
I'm spoke
for sure Zach babe I'm feeling like like
a little like scratching my throat yeah
and I'll be like that's not the symptom
so you're making it oh yeah you're gonna
Gaslight I love that you're thinking I
know I mean that's the scratch is the
symptom but like he'll be like and and
runny nose a little bit but he'll be
like my stomach hurts like I think I got
what you guys got I'm like
no no you didn't I think that's also
it's just the time of year now like the
seasons are changing there's been like a
real palpable shift in weather here in
New York like it's that gorgeous fall
chill like really one of the best times
to be in New York and that's when
everyone gets sick so just get ready
yeah I wouldn't know if the weather here
has changed I haven't left my house in
like five days let me check the weather
app
let me check the weather app is it still
in the 90s
87 oh no it gets to 90 later today oh
you know Ben is like a firm um hater of
the weather app like he refuses Ben has
like so many weird things like if we're
driving somewhere I'm like it's not like
a complicated route it's like obviously
like the Long Island Expressway or the
BQE like
and I put it in like Apple Maps like the
app he will pull over to the side of the
road and do it on Google my husband too
what like okay if we're going like
to holidays like for sure I don't know
plus like whichever one they're using
stinks agreed we're always late they all
stink honestly ever since googlebot ways
and corrupted it because Waze was taking
over they all stink you just have to
like get out your map in your magnifying
glass and find the back roads
hundred percent
um so while it is Tuesday and that's not
great it is a huge day here at the
morning toast because we announced a
little while ago that Shannon Ford would
be joining toast News Network and season
two of her show launches today a lot of
you guys already know and love Shannon
her episode on the toast was so
critically acclaimed I believe it's in
the running for a Peabody Award
um you guys loved her so much and her
podcast is so good she worked so hard on
it like I feel like sometimes you'll see
like people doing podcasts just because
like that's what people do and not
really like giving it the attention it
requires Shannon does video and audio
content her video content is so stunning
she's so stunning She Looks So Glamorous
in every episode she lives this like
fabulous interesting life she's funny
um and it's really like an IT girl
podcast it's called probably a podcast
but it should be called the it girl
that's so funny because that's also what
we wanted to name Lauren Elizabeth's
podcast we're just friends with so many
it girls or we're like Beyond unoriginal
like come up with one good idea and like
use it multiple times I didn't even
remember no I think we're consistent and
just like goes to show that we're
friends with such it girls
like maybe it's because we are it girls
and we attract that it fellow it energy
I didn't realize that that's what we
wanted to call um Lauren Elizabeth's
podcast do you remember now that I'm
reminding you
like it was just another idea that was
floating amongst the others I felt
really good about it but I was I have no
recollection I was brutally rebuffed
well I'm just so excited for us like I'm
so grateful to Shannon for joining our
little fam and I think you guys are
gonna love it so you can watch it on
YouTube but she's also available you
know anywhere podcasts can be found and
she's a premium girly there's a lot
going on in her life she has like an
international man I know I feel like
there's always a lot going on in her
life just in general she's just like one
of those people but right now is
definitely an interesting time to be
following her to be listening to her
podcast she like lives between New York
and Nashville which is like goals goals
and then she's constantly going across
the pond to see her new man's who is
subject a former subject of her majesty
the queen
so it always comes to get him on the
toes and ask him what the temperature is
like I wonder if he's like a
monarchophile what's the word uh
royalist
monarchist yeah
or maybe he's a hater
I think a lot of young people in the UK
I mean I don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] but
I think like a lot of people like young
people are like rebelling against the
monarchy in the UK I don't think so I
really I do I really don't but I really
don't have to have Shan's man
's bands
um also she has a ton of like previous
episodes if you want to go catch up with
Shannon like learn a little bit more
about her and she does great guests I
was on it so obviously she has a really
low bar for guests
um she did a really good episode with
Hannah burner so there's just good [ __ ]
on there and it's premium as [ __ ] so why
wouldn't you join it it has the TNN
stamp of approval big time
big big time so you know just Mogul
things
for the day yesterday was like a major
Mogul day we were booked and busy
like the thing about being a mogul is
like sometimes I don't want to be one
you know
like sometimes I just want to lay in my
business want to be a regular girl
oh thank you I'm so wait back to Shannon
I believe now
we are the industries leading podcast
Network for redheads
we have two we have two plus we have the
redheads book club which is constantly
elevating the voices of redheads and
Reed heads and Shannon is a natural
redhead yes not that it makes a
difference but it does it does
and I just I thought that was
interesting I think per capita we have
the most redheads oh for sure because
now we're at like 10 redheads
right because we're two redheads plus
the redheads show and I think we have
now 10 shows on TNN so like
just makes you think it does make you
think I have to start comparing with
other networks but um
I I don't know how many other red-headed
podcasts there are in the big leagues I
know the only other red-headed girl is
JC Murray of what we said
um
but other than she
I don't know what redheads are out here
doing it oh you know what's cool Sorry
Conan
oh wait Prince Harry he doesn't have a
podcast no his wife does
um wait also
now this makes me think ready except
Conan kind of threw a wrench in what I
was about to say next like do you think
you're the biggest female redhead
podcast host
I mean I do what I don't know if any
that are bigger I was gonna say redhead
period but Conan is definitely bigger
than us so you'll have to be the female
let me look at the charts let me look
yeah I don't see a lot of redhead
representation on the charts yeah but
like maybe the person who hosts the
daily anonymously like is a redhead they
just like don't put their picture
everywhere well that wouldn't count
because because if no one's tuning into
to the Daily for like the dynamic
personalities like they're tuning in
just for the moon and like if you're not
a visible redhead then like you're not
out here doing the work
you're not making like an impact for the
movement no and like for the redhead
Community you're not right sorry no I
completely agree I'm looking through the
top podcasts okay there's Conan
classic there we are I didn't see a
redhead before I saw us
so that would make you the biggest
podcaster who's a female redhead yes I'm
gonna add that to my bio because I never
know what the [ __ ] to put in there 100
like Jackie's and Instagram influencer
podcaster friend yeah Lifestyle brand
Enthusiast she's a mess like writing a
bio is probably like the worst part top
10 one of the most painful experiences
of someone's life and you have to
constantly be updated she is a mess
following stop not the amassed
Jackie's so right jack Claudia can be
seen on The Today Show Steve Harvey yeah
like Bravos Watch What Happens live like
just kill me because all the things like
that are like notable happened to me 10
years ago you know yeah no your book
I had to recently update my bio I added
my tour my book TNN I just feel like the
things that are most interesting about
me like aren't the things you put in a
bio
no like literally who cares yeah yeah
people like the BIOS they only care
about the fake [ __ ] not the real [ __ ] so
true like if you have a good bio you're
a fake person totally like I want to
know how many books you read last year
oh my God by the way I officially
reached over 100 books read
since you got your Kindle
since I started my Goodreads so when
when I started reading the December of
2019 was it or 2020. that's amazing how
many books have you read this year so
far let me check mine 43 wow and your
goal is 50. my goal was 35 but now it's
50 and I think I'll hit it no problem
let me see how many I've read so far
this year 26 and I was
good for you by the way that's good yeah
my goal for the year was 30. so I'll
meet it oh you'll have this from
redheads books hopefully we'll take like
a nice trip at the end of the year
that's where we get all of our reading
yeah
I was talking to bed about it because
like I saw in my Goodreads it was at 101
and I'm like oh my God like I was like
so excited and proud of myself and he's
like that's great like being all
patronized and he's fake literally
called out right um but I was just
trying to explain to him like why it's
such a big deal and it's obviously like
great to have read but it's also great
for me to have like done something I
swore I would never do because like I'm
so stubborn
um and there's so many things I would
love to like in an ideal world yeah I
would love to be a girl who goes for
runs but we all know that's never gonna
happen and reading used to be running
yeah so maybe I'll start running or
skiing
I would love to ski but I just am not
I'm not physically capable like I'm
really not I think you are I think you
should give it another chance
uh By the way when I was watching The
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills in
Aspen and they were so fabulous and like
their Fendi jumpsuits and just like
it's there's nothing more elegant and
rich and cool than skiing like I would
love to take like a weekend trip the one
time I went I swear to God my legs were
gonna fall off
I think I think you could do it now
because I weigh less
it was a lot of work for sure there was
a lot of quest listeners I did not
yeah I the part of the reason why I
thought my legs were gonna fall off was
because my entire body weight was like
being
heralded on my shins which aren't in
particularly great it's also really hard
on your shins at first even sometimes
like once your skilled you just have to
lean onto your shins and it really hurts
yeah I do think being a bit more
light light will help you I think you
should try it again at some point
I know but it's also it's not something
like that's just like let's just try it
to get to the mountain with all of your
[ __ ]
and not faint is borderline impossible
so just to try it but also like all the
work that I had to put in before that
yeah
it's not like oh what if I just you know
went to the mountain it's like a whole
thing yeah well I think the opportunity
will present itself at some point for
you I would love it like is there like a
private Mountain yeah
like if somebody would invite me to
their home it's like a private Mountain
where like I could just put my skis on
in my bedroom and then walk outside like
ski out
that I'll just try it because if it
sucks how do I get home
yeah that I think you like take the
chair lift up and then ski down to your
house like if you live in the middle on
a mountain you can ski out and then ski
down the rest of the mountain
but I don't know how do I get to the
I've never done it
it never skied out
so
that sounds like a luxury that I would
definitely like to afford yes for sure
okay bucket list bucket listings we've
got a great show I did watch the Emmys
last night and I actually have a lot of
thoughts I'm excited to talk about it
and we've got unburdened yourself so I
feel like we should Dive Right In we're
busy girls we don't have them burning
ourselves actually we have unburdened we
have unburden yourselves
I didn't say that yeah you didn't no I
didn't
roll the tapes we have them burning
yourselves at gmail.com we do by the way
I plan to unburden themselves okay
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
ZipRecruiter hiring is a challenge is a
challenge especially right now when you
have so much on your plate luckily
there's one place you can go to where
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
where growing businesses connected to
qualified candidates the place is
ziprecruiter.com toast so ZipRecruiter
does the work for you they use powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job
excuse me
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply ZipRecruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on ZipRecruiter get a chance quality
candidate within the first day and it's
a no wonder zip recruiter is the number
one rated hiring site based on G2
satisfaction ratings as of January 1st
2022. right now you can try ZipRecruiter
for free when our listeners go to
ziprecruiter.com toast that's
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t ziprecruiter.com toast
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
great okay our first story Emmy Awards
2022 all the winners losers fashion
moments
Etc
so let's go through the winner shall we
yes because
um I just happened to have like at 7 59
I saw something on Instagram like oh the
Emmys and I turned it on and I just
started to watch it because there was
like nothing else to watch and I have to
say I really enjoyed it I thought it was
super well done they wasted no [ __ ]
time with dumb Shenanigans [ __ ] Keenan
was excellent and I thought it was a
gorgeous Affair really wow I'm so happy
for you
they they got their [ __ ] together it was
much tighter you know it was like Awards
presenters Awards presenters like no
dumb like [ __ ] packages
no packages no Keenan embarrassing
himself like he was doing a good job he
was being funny and he was getting from
point A to point B great
um I did not watch but here are the list
of winners and like we were familiar we
watched so many of the shows yeah so it
was nice I mean White Lotus swept
completely it was Ned schneebly's night
and nobody else's
that's the guy Steve Zahn no Ned
schnably is the writer and director of
the show it's like his baby and he won
on like all the major categories and he
played he was played by Ned schneidley
his name is Mike White okay and someone
also messaged me that he directed The
Emoji Movie which won a Razzie so he is
on his way to regard
this is huge this is huge adding another
layer right okay let's go through the
winners we'll share the plot share our
thoughts yeah first Outstanding Drama
Series which is like the big award yeah
succession
oh I was so happy for them it was so
crazy to see them all together but then
the guy who was making the speech like
took a dig at a monarchy
like why you gotta make it about King
Charles it was like kind of losery like
you just wanted an Emmy and you're
talking about the King right and I think
Brian Cox who plays Logan is British and
he was like he didn't say anything I
think he was offended by that
no it was just like hella [ __ ]
unnecessary and they left the queen out
of in memoriam
she's not an actress yes she is
she's been in things she's inspired many
a program the crown there's no show
without her um she literally just died
there's an in-memory I'm like pay some
[ __ ] respect no I don't think it was
necessary and they left out Norm
Macdonald
that's what I saw no way because he was
literally nominated last night
he was nominated posthumously but in
memoriam segment no I didn't watch it in
Memorial no offense like it makes me sad
like I don't like I don't have my eyes
glued for who they snub you know yeah I
heard they snubbed Norm
that's moronic and I don't know if I I
can cannot imagine that's true he was
literally nominated last night
I'm just telling you what I heard
Session One
um they were all at the same table
except Kendall Roy was at the White
Lotus table maybe there was like not not
enough space But like I just thought
that was weird
well they're both HBO tables
oh yeah and maybe he's seeing someone in
the White Lotus cast
and Tom won for lead actors or
supporting actor well okay outstanding
lead actor in a drama series went to Lee
jong-jae from squid game well deserved
then outstanding lead actress in a drama
series went to Zendaya first euphoria
and that was historic and everyone in
the room was just like it was literally
like Zendaya's mom it's felt like it was
like about she looked like unreal best
dressed Best Dressed her hair like was
this cute little baby doll style that
really went with the dress she looked
incredible like she is that [ __ ] Her
speech was really beautiful and she's
really beautiful and it was just like
sad that Tom Holland wasn't there why
wasn't he there because she was just
like a solo night out for her I don't
know like celebrities like like to do
that like when like I think because when
you show up with your mans especially if
you're not often
photographed with your man's it becomes
about that and not about your
accomplishments like that's why Taylor's
like never at the Grammys which are all
one you know I yeah but like how could
anything really dwarf her
accomplishments at this point you know
no it's true but I don't know if that
was the reason why or maybe scheduling
but like make it work scheduling it
actually is a really busy week globally
it is the Kelly Clarkson show has moved
to New York we haven't even spoken about
that so exciting for the city and she
did like a little promo video
um singing Welcome to New York by Taylor
Swift and like honestly there's never
been a greater piece of work so does
this mean Kelly's moving to New York as
a woman yes unless like as a human as a
mom yeah
I don't know does that mean she's gonna
enroll her kids in the private school
system here I gotta find out where they
go to school not to be a freak that's
really freaky yeah no that's actually
like really inappropriate I take it back
sorry
um I don't know if like if she would
come and like for three or four days a
week
bang out like two shows a day that's
what a lot of people do and then move
to Montana or wherever she lives
Nashville
yeah
I don't know I don't know okay back to
the Emmys outstanding supporting actor
and in drama series Matthew McFadden's
succession who plays Tom also known as
Mr Darcy
when he gave a speech and it turned out
he was British and like I just didn't
put that together even though I knew he
played Mr Darcy it was quite jarring
what did he say
um
he was just like so like Shook and like
so happy and he obviously just loves his
job and like loves being on succession
and he's like definitely a funny guy in
person what was so weird about last
night was like and I don't remember an
Emmy's season where there was
so much of this where like every
category had like three people from the
same show so he was up against Kieran
Nicholas Braun and Greg Kieran Colgan so
like it was weird yeah that is weird and
Severance also
I know every show dope stick had like
three people per category there was
really like four or five shows
that had like multiple candidates in
every category and then there was like
Sydney Sweeney being nominated twice
once for Zendaya I mean Zendaya one's
for Euphoria and once for White Lotus
and she didn't win for either no she
looks great though
um actually I was not a fan I think
sometimes she looks like really just not
fashionable and so considering that I
thought chilled really good
yeah who made her dress I don't know
I want to say Tory Burch can you just
double check before I make my point
about that
Oscar de la Renta okay because she has
this like big partnership with Tory
Burch and so she wears a lot of Tory
Burch Couture and the brand is just like
a little matronly for her she's like the
youngest hottest thing in Hollywood
right now like she's wearing Grandma
dresses yeah I feel that like and that
one last night while it was better it's
still a grandma dress yeah I I no lies
were told
Pete Davidson was also at the awards and
he was looking cute did he seem sad
actually yes
what is going on that was my first
thought
it's just like want to know what's going
on
it was also just like a big night for
comedy because obviously SNL was
nominated a bunch of times and then
there's the comedy category for the
specials Gerard Carmichael one
um
it was just like a big night for like I
just felt like there was a lot of
comedians Bowen Yang was nominated and
he was there Lauren Michaels was there
and Lauren Michaels they won like the
variety sketch comedy it's like yeah
what else yeah sure okay let me finish
the winners outstanding supporting
actress in a drama series Julia Garner
Ozark outstanding comedy series Ted
lasso we can now confirm oh that was
nice that it is a really good show
outstanding actor in a comedy series
Jason stake is Ted lasso honestly like
totally deserved I loved Ted lasso every
time they won I wanted to cry totally
outstanding actress in a comedy series
Jean Smart hacks oh the way that the
Emmys keep giving Gene Smart her
rightfully deserved award when there's
so many good women in that category like
I'm grateful for like Hannah einbender
did not win
um so I thought like maybe they were
over I mean I don't think she deserved
to win but I thought maybe like you know
the gene smart thing was just like a a
fluke last year yeah no I looking at the
category I hadn't watched anything else
but she deserves it like completely
handily next outstanding supporting
actor in a comedy series Brett Goldstein
Ted lasso Roy Kent right yeah Kendall
Roy Roy Kent it's definitely confusing
yes I um was so happy that he won my
Jewish King he's so hot Brett Goldstein
I think he was at my bar mitzvah
um and I think he deserves a Nobel Peace
Prize for that one line he delivered
that changed my life
I think you might be dying
when that girl has bad breath like I
actually never laugh at TV and I swear
to God I think I peed my pants it was so
funny me too next outstanding supporting
actress in a comedy series Cheryl Lee
Ralph Abbott Elementary you watch that
yeah I do I haven't watched like all of
it but I watched a good chunk of the
first season and like Abbott Elementary
is the cutest TV show and it's you just
are gonna be rooting for them because
like their pajamas and PJs like they had
all this money
for um to do press for the Emmys like
that the network gave them and they
donated every single dollar to give
school supplies to the public schools
like which is so moronic that like we
even have to do that but like they're
like a show that like highlights like
the trials and tribulations of being a
public school teacher in an underfunded
and like low-income neighborhood and
they're like walking the walk and
talking the talk like I just love them
and the show is [ __ ] funny that's
awesome yeah and Chessie is in it I
heard and Jesse's a redhead
to ship a podcast
hopefully not next outstanding limited
series The White Lotus
then outstanding actor in a limited
series or movie Michael Heaton dopesick
standing actress in a limited series of
movie Amanda Seyfried the Dropout that
was shocking yeah she was up against
Julia Garner inventing Anna Lily James
Pam and Tommy Margaret quality made
Sarah Paulson impeachment Tony Collette
the staircase
I thought Margaret quality could have or
should have won same with Sarah Paulson
she was amazing as that annoying [ __ ]
in impeachment yeah these are all shows
that like I intended to watch like
really truly like still on my
contemplate that I just never did I feel
like I watched I just got in the way I
feel like I watched Pam and Tommy though
um I did it was good okay then
outstanding supporting actress in a
comedy series Jennifer Coolidge the
White Lotus
she gave okay the one thing I want to
say about the Emmys is that like award
shows are always like playing the music
for people every single person who got
on stage had a clock in front of them
and they I kept saying oh my God I only
have 30 seconds like they gave people no
time yeah and this year I guess they
like asked all the nominees to submit
like a list of people they would want to
thank so that when the person ended up
winning they put like the gene hack
smart would like to thank her brother
blank and her agent like it was so
disingenuous and like if we're not gonna
listen to the people who are winning
like that's what we're watching for no
like this more than ever I felt like
they were cutting people off and to
their credit they did end at 11 o'clock
not 11 30 but like cut something else
yeah for real like why it was actually
like rude That is rude and it like trips
people up and probably makes people go
longer as opposed to like if I knew I
had this much time up as instead of
being like sorry oh you know wasting
time on being like I know I need to wrap
this up yeah like shut up like just talk
instead of talking about wrapping it up
you're wasting time and I also feel like
there needs to be someone in the back
like editorializing the amount of time
people have because it's like Jennifer
Lotus should have more time than
Jennifer who just like won again yeah no
they definitely use discretion like
Jennifer Lopez is that what I called you
I'm not feeling well they definitely
choose like they pick and choose who
they get you know kicked off like Amanda
Seyfried while she is like A-list like
she's not like super like you know
she wasn't like inspiring anyone with
her speech like she got kicked off but
um you know the woman from I'm so sorry
I cannot remember her name from
Abbott Elementary like saying and was
like literally giving a speech I was
bringing people to tears about just like
never give up on your dreams like look
at me like it was just like and nobody
played the music like as they shouldn't
have that's what it was just there needs
to be someone in the back being like do
people want to hear from this person are
they really saying something impactful
or can we like save some minutes here
yeah they definitely use judgment but
that's also not fair like everyone
worked equally as hard like give them a
minute they give a minute
yeah they get like 30 to 45 seconds
okay then we have outstanding variety
talk series Last Week Tonight with John
Oliver
like that category being like Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Stephen Colbert like
I'm sorry like I'm like I have such a
hatred of late night talk show late
night TV because it's literally like I'm
sorry it's talentless hacks like it's
all like
it's like how we feel about David
Letterman like I've just started to
recently like really hate that group of
people yeah because I feel like they got
famous at a time where like they were
the only people getting famous like they
weren't giving out shows to like Asian
women you know like it was like straight
white men and like they're not funny
like literally it's a fact that like
Jimmy Kimmel is not [ __ ] funny
they're not funny the shows aren't funny
how many writers do they have on these
shows how many people do they have
working on them to put out this piece of
garbage every single night oh and
there's like six of them yeah it's just
not interesting no and so the fact that
like they're still getting these
prestigious nominations like you know
who deserves that award like Cody Coast
podcast like people actually like that
yeah
it was just the pot like but also not to
make it about there should be one
podcast award within the Emmys like
sorry I agree especially for people like
to do video
yeah especially for one that's hosted by
two sisters one that's right I had one
that's fat Burnett
just think about it
um and I did feel like they were getting
a little bit more creative like nailed
it with Nicole buyer which is like
actually a genuinely
hysterical show that got nominated in
like the competition yeah outstanding
competition program she was nominated
but lizzo's watch out for the big girls
one didn't and you know what was so
crazy you didn't it's on Amazon Prime
it's like a worldwide search for like
really talented backup dancers who are
not like the traditional like what you
would come to expect from a dancer's
body that's cool um yeah and now they're
going on a world tour like it was
actually really good yeah like Liz it
was actually involved in it and she like
loves the girls and all the girls were
there oh that's so cool
but um it was a crazy kind of upset
because RuPaul always wins yeah
and RuPaul was there like he obviously
thought he was going to win yeah well
it's it's nice like it could go to
someone else someone else could have an
Emmy on their shelf no it's so true and
now I feel like lizzo is definitely like
in the egot
she has the E and the G but could she be
regard
the O is the hardest she could write a
song for a movie yeah
she'll get there okay well that's your
Emmys recap
um there was one thing I wanted to say
before we wrapped up okay and it was
just to kind of go off of how much I
[ __ ] hate Jimmy Kimmel great
so he presented with Will Arnett and
they did this incredibly unfunny Oh shot
a bit shocking where like Jimmy Kimmel
was like dead on the floor the whole
time like Willard dragged him out by the
by his feet dropped him at the
microphone Will Arnett like did the
presentation and
when they announced the winner
who was Quinta Brown from Abbott
Elementary which is just like this if
you if you've been following Abbott
Elementary it's just like this
incredible story like it's just this
feel-good show and
it's written by a black woman like it's
it's like a great Triumph and it's it
was this moment for her and Jimmy Kimmel
stayed on the floor
like pretending to be dead for her
speech like get it got in her way like
she literally couldn't even get to the
microphone
that's so funny
I can't see no it's hilarious
ha no that's really I was like you're
kidding me like this is a huge moment
and now in every picture
your dumb Dopey body is get the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] get up it really [ __ ] pissed me
off
get up
what the [ __ ] was it
oh and above all it was not a funny bit
so it's like if you're gonna like Risk
being rude you gotta be funny and
unfortunately Jimmy Kimmel being funny
is not something he really does but it
sounds hysterical Claude no it was so
dumb and then at the at the uh
afterwards when they do press for all
the winners somebody asked like what did
you think about that and it's very clear
she's you know a political Queen she's
on ABC he's on ABC I do believe
um they know each other like he
might have even been like somewhat
helpful in getting her on ABC so like
she wasn't gonna like you know
be rude so she was like well I don't
know what the internet thinks like I
thought it was fine it was like she was
she was she wasn't telling the truth but
she was being she was like saying the
right things like not with the
enthusiasm of someone who believes that
she had no like energy she was like Oh I
thought it was funny I think it's
hysterical one of the funniest things
I've ever heard
it really [ __ ] pissed me off like
and other people on the internet who are
literally going around photoshopping all
of her images and getting his body out
all right how stupid gorgeous
I like the hate that I have for like the
jimmies well actually I kind of like
Jimmy Fallon for Jimmy Kimmel
specifically and like all like the late
night hosts who I just feel like are
really undeserving of all that they have
accomplished like I'm sorry I don't know
if that's like mean to undermine their
entire career but like it's just how I
feel
um my hatred has grown stronger
especially when like there were so many
shows last night that came from
streaming and aren't like the typical
like these aren't you know people who
were just handed TV shows you know what
I mean yeah
so it just felt when they did that
category I'm like you're kidding
you're kidding
damn yeah okay well that's yeah it was a
good night yeah I'm glad you enjoyed it
I'm shocked that you watched no I know
and I did enjoy it it was really
star-studded like Reese Witherspoon was
there Connie Britton was there oh yeah
um Amy polar it was just it was premium
wonderful are you ready for our next
story
are you I'm just not feeling great today
so oh my God it's contagious
the next story is brought to you by
kitch they say that hair care is the new
skincare but there's one brand that is
taking it to the next level with a
cult-like following kitch has created
game changing Essentials the beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time saving towels
kitchen knows hair care doesn't stop in
the shower
so whatever your budget your skin type
your hair type kids believes you deserve
little indulgences at affordable prices
morning noon and night they were started
in 2010 by selling their hair ties door
to door and now they are a self-funded
female founded and carried in over 20
000 retail locations so they offer a lot
of great different hair products so if
you sleep like an animal like myself
they're satin pillowcases caps and eye
masks are great so you don't wake up and
have to redo your entire head of hair
this is only something I've recently
started doing and I cannot believe how
much time and heat I've wasted on my
hair by not just sleeping with a satin
pillowcase
they also have shampoo and conditioner
bars that makes bottle-free beauty the
future they have heatless satin curling
rollers that people on Tick Tock are
obsessed with they have quick dry hair
towels if you are like me and it takes
24 hours for your hair to dry it might
be time to buy yourself one of the quick
drying towels and their classic hair
ties and scrunchies I also love their
claw Clips because I have long thick
hair and a traditional claw clip is not
going to cut it Kitsch is offering you
30 off your entire order at mykitch.com
toast that's 30 off anything and
everything at
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast
mykitch.com toast for 30 off your order
gorgeous
gorgeous
okay our next story Ray J is on the war
path oh yeah he is so I mean Kris Jenner
claiming that he filmed three sex tapes
with Kim Kardashian to get the right one
for Miss Chris Ray J is doing whatever
it takes to clear his name the singer
who infamously appeared in the sex tape
with X Kim Kardashian slammed Kris
Jenner on Saturday after she took a lie
detector test he claims was fake so we
talked about this last week Kris Jenner
went on James Corden and the lie
detector man was the man from Lisa
Vanderpump he is the man that I believe
like David dobrik uses in his Vlogs he
is the one and only lie detector test
configurer in Los Angeles there's only
one lie detector guy in L.A and 100 he
administered Chris's lie detector test
where James Corden asked her if she
sold Kim's sex tape and she said no the
lie detector determined that was true
and this upset Ray J because he is back
to square one insisting that Crystal the
tape made them film it three times
because she didn't like how Kim looked
and he's putting up some presentations
on his Instagram
um trying to prove that this is the case
so while I did see some of the proof I
didn't feel like any of it was like you
know
bulletproof like it could just be a
piece of paper that he wrote you know
take one take two yeah
um
and I don't know I just and perhaps I'm
just a Kardashian blind loyalist
apologist and I own that but I just have
a hard time believing okay because I
feel like at first you know they were
before the Kardashians ever addressed it
people used to say like Chris sold it
and I was probably like yeah she
probably did but like it worked so who
cares like you know what we're past that
um but then they started you know
addressing the fact that people think it
and that made me think no because if
they did actually sell it they would
have just like continued to ignore yeah
they don't have to address it so the way
that they handled it made me think that
no and so no one was even talking about
it anymore when they did that James
Corden thing and if the Kardashians
didn't want to answer it James Corden
wouldn't have made like they obviously
had approval right right
so the fact that they're like not
against talking about the fact
that people think it was Chris it makes
me think it wasn't Chris yeah I don't
know what I thought it was I feel like
it was like gonna get out or something
and then they
got involved in order to
not like in order to get make money with
everyone else get ahead of it yeah
perhaps also
I remember watching season one of the
Kardashians and like emotions were high
like the girls are not actors and not
season one
no like I've seen them act in some [ __ ]
and they stink like they're not actors
yeah
like those were raw real emotions but I
remember when she was gonna go on Tyra
even if it wasn't Chris who sold it I
don't think it's Ray J Who Sold it like
I feel like we can let Regina like we
don't think it's you isn't it like some
no I think it's Ray J like uh literally
a year ago Ray J's manager like right
someone is manager
yeah perhaps but like I don't think it
was Ray J
especially after this like he really is
intention wants to clear his name
yeah the thing is like I don't really
care like I have moved on yeah I have
you seen the sex tape no
I have somebody showed it to me when I
was in high school like I'm not gonna
say his name because he's married now
and actually just saw him he's a nice
boy
um but he showed it to me and I was like
literally like what I've never seen like
you know like porn before I was like
it was like really graphic
I know I don't I don't even know
so I have moved on you know I've moved
that fateful day in junior year yeah me
too I don't know what I believe but I'm
not like mad at anyone I'm not this
isn't like stopping me from being a fan
over AJ no I like his ear buds raycon
you do love his earbuds
here's like a tech company yeah raycon
he puts the ray in raycon yeah so I just
look I don't care I don't care question
do you think Kim and Rachel are gonna
get back together
I do feel like she's like a little still
hung up on Pete and when she kind of
heals from that Journey maybe she's
willing to explore things again with Ray
J but um I'm not sure there's really no
telling the future you never know
honestly that's like less crazy than Kim
and Pete getting together in the first
place hundred percent I mean I am still
holding out hope for Kim and Reggie Bush
like that really was like OTP I'm
holding out hope for Kim and Chris
Humphries
I'm not I don't think two people have
ever hated each other more no and you
know what like
Chris Humphrey says every right to hate
Kim because as much as I love her like I
can admit that wasn't her finest moment
I think she would admit that
you know whose moment it really wasn't
fine is he either Chloe why
like during that show like that series
like she was kind of mean what do you
mean
like when they did Kim and Chris getting
married or yeah Kim and Chris getting
married what did she do so
it's like mean to like Chris and like
his sister
do you remember it was just like so
awkward like everyone was so unhappy
um and they were trying not to be and it
was hard okay I need to go back and
launch but it honestly like
it was not a good time to be a
Kardashian it was also weird that like
Kim married someone with the same name
as her mom yeah and it's like an
alternate spelling too
weird okay are you ready for our next
story yeah in today's news of fools who
are disrespecting the queen Howard Stern
slams annoying U.S coverage of the
Queen's death he says enough
oh my God this is tough for me because
you know you're too crazy yeah we really
look up to Howard Stern Howard Stern has
had enough of Queen Elizabeth II the
outspoken radio personality slam the
wall to all U.S media coverage of the
monarchs I can't hear this it's a tirade
during Monday segment of the Howard
Stern Show he said it's weird traditions
in everything and I'm like Jesus enough
with the queen he told his co-host Robin
Quivers when her death was brought up I
mean it's America we don't have a queen
okay that's like not like that crazy I
know but like he's not here for all the
Pomp and Circumstance by the way that's
like fine with me like I am okay with
you know looking up to people who I
don't share every opinion with like I'm
okay with that at least you can say like
I'm glad that [ __ ] is dead that's what
I thought like he was because he could
be a little crazy sometimes yeah no he
didn't say that he's just like not here
for all of our obsession with it
um but that's why you tune into the
morning toast because that's fine he's
not here for it that's fine but here
we're going to keep you updated on one
Queen story a day in some way Queen and
Jason until the end of September I can
guarantee it yeah and like not everyone
wants to tune in and listen to a curly
headed [ __ ] okay
I'm kidding I'm kidding I just wanted to
hurt Howard like he hurt me yeah I'm
lashing out I guess he didn't get
invited to the funeral
right oh clearly someone's a little
better jealous
jealous do you see Prince Charles I'm
sorry King Charles cavaliers final is
going viral like for his fingers
um like the way with the pen no two
things he's got everything he's doing
he's like getting roasted one is because
like they're calling his fingers it's
really mean honestly like sausage
fingers because he's got like Chunky
body shaming him they're body shaming
the king okay well as the official
spokesperson for fat fingered [ __ ]
um I think that this is disgusting I
think I stand with Charles a lot of us
are really insecure you don't think we'd
all like long lean fingers some of us
weren't born that way and some of us no
matter how much [ __ ] weight we lose
still have big fat [ __ ] hands okay
and some of us no matter how much weight
we gain still have pretty slim fingers
no it's not right like the way you
prance around with those pointy little
[ __ ] it's crazy like my fingers have
expanded like a little bit since being
like a big fat [ __ ]
but it's crazy my ring sizes are so
small like my wedding ring my my
engagement ring is pretty small but it
still fits but like my wedding band is
literally a size three
I don't even want to tell you what mine
is okay
but my engagement ring is like a three
and three quarters
um huge what's yours
I don't really feel like sharing I feel
like you're a six seven which is like an
average size
I would prefer to share my pant size
than my ring size okay okay what kind of
pants do you wear [ __ ] [ __ ] off weren't
you saying the other day that we should
all share our weights
yeah but everyone else has to go first
and then I'll decide that's funny
anyways
um
so I just would love like weight
transparency like
what does like like okay there's a body
that I like like what do you weigh yeah
yeah I feel like Kim's always telling us
what she weighs which I love okay
that's for sure but like that's not what
I'm referring no no I know regular
people I know but I I like like knowing
also I think we're like around the same
height as Kim so it's actually
interesting that's like so sad because
I'm so far from her when someone's like
really really tall though it's like I
can't even relate no I was just having
this conversation I forget who oh with
Heather McMahon because she's so tall
and she was talking about her she really
carries her weight very well and she
does because she's so [ __ ] tall and
actually it's like not fair it's not
fair 12 people can eat more and and then
I was saying Ben has the same thing Ben
carries his weight extremely well it's
not fair and I'm just like a roly-poly
Oly over here trying to get out the door
yeah
Prince King Charles is being made fun of
like the he's like was pushing around
his pen things like pets and servants
yeah just being kind of a tyrant
yeah no he definitely gives like bad
boss energy like is he gonna be a
tyrannical King I feel like those days
are passed because the kings and queens
really don't have power so it's like
powerless okay you want to be crazy like
ghost do in your room right um go to
your room
but is he gonna be like Charles the
Terrible
he's gonna be Charles in Charge Charles
the Terrible
Turtles are you ready for our next story
we're not at the fifth and finally no
but this next story I'm really excited
to talk about
because it's some Elvis news
have you seen the news
check it I feel like this is the fifth
no did you choose six no here one was
Emmys two was Ray J three was Howard
Stern four is what I'm about to say oh
but we just like went on so many
tangents yeah four was my ring size
right right so Sofia Coppola is coming
out with this Priscilla Presley biopic
and the cast is coming in guess who's
playing Elvis
which was another biopit yeah but it's
about Priscilla but no it's totally
giving like sad fraudulent energy it's
giving like when there were two Snow
White and the huntsmans you know yeah no
but it's like the elf like Elvis is
Austin Butler if anybody wants to make
another Elvis movie you're gonna have to
cast us a butler
okay wait so who was playing Elvis Jacob
alordi
it's not like a little losery
on the same like I'm embarrassed for
Jacob like
this is really weird who's playing
Priscilla Priscilla is being played by
um Kaylee sponny but like to me Olivia
degange is Priscilla so if you use
Kaylee spawning I just need to she's
from mayor of East Town in bad times at
the El Royale
like good luck how do you spell Kaylee
how do you spell
c-a-i-l-e-c-a-i-l-l-e-e space
s-p-a-e-n-y
I don't see it
yeah no I just like the
I feel like this kind of is behavior is
really beneath Sophia Coppola like I
know the whole dad is Francis Ford
Coppola like the whole thing is odd to
me especially because like we got the
Elvis movie and this is like felvis
no I'm like I'm literally ashamed no
this would be like if Harry Styles like
he didn't get the big movie so now he's
gonna play it Elvis in the small movie
no because the way I'm like so shook up
by this information You're All Shook Up
I'm All Shook Up and to be honest I feel
like Jacob already just got like a
little less hot honestly no way no like
if Sophia Copeland wants to make a movie
about Priscilla Presley I absolutely
love that you have to cast Austin Butler
and elevator gange otherwise
what are you doing what's the point what
are you doing
and Miss Elvis
I don't why
honestly the more that I sat back and
like marinated with the film The More I
thought it was actually a horrendous
movie for real
what about all the standing ovations
that say otherwise
oh well that changes things for sure it
was good
like it was entertaining but as a film
it was bad
like really and that's not to take away
from Austin Butler like I actually still
think he deserves to be nominated for an
Oscar
I think Tom Hanks deserves to be jailed
secluded Island Cummings deserves jail
but I think the film was not good I
don't think it was inaccurate no not
maybe not accurate I don't think it was
a
effective retelling of Elvis's story I
think if that's the story we're leaving
to like a younger generation like
nobody's gonna respect all this would
you respect a loser
no no I wouldn't yeah
so you're saying we do need another
Elvis movie
kind of
but like Austin Butler is Elvis like
that's what the movie was successful in
yeah
so maybe that's what Sophia Coppola felt
like she saw the movie she said this
isn't what we should be leaving the
children I'm gonna do it my own way
because maybe Sophia Coppola believes
that the children are a future
maybe are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am in weird collab news
Swedish House Mafia talk about their
affordable Ikea collab
Swedish Alpha Mafia is streaming I'm
sorry about that again Swedish House
Mafia is teaming up with Swedish founded
retailer Ikea speaking to People
magazine about the collaboration the
house music super group shared their
experience growing up with the brand in
Sweden and how the retailer played a
very large role in their lives the two
Scandinavian powerhouses joined forces
to produce
obey Grand sad
a limited collect collection that will
enable the many rising creatives in
music and Digital Arts to produce their
to build their home Studios at an
affordable price the products will sign
me up where was this a month ago the
products will be launched in the U.S and
globally in October 2022. so it's like
the the line is for like Furniture you
need if you build like an at-home DJ
Studio yeah it's very neat Studio spaces
vinyl collections DJ tables
that's kind of cool
this is very Niche I do feel like you
know obviously Swedish House Mafia
Swedish Ikea I get it
um but I do feel like them sitting down
with People magazine to talk about like
a Furniture collab is so beneath them
it's giving uh Bachelor Nation no wait I
know that's why it's bizarre but it's
Unique New York
but the collab itself is an interesting
idea but also it's like Swedish House
mavi like can barely get together again
to do like a final show at Burning Man
with millions of people and like it's so
true now they're like pulling Kelly
Clarkson and designing Furniture
together
it's Unique New York
I feel as though you needed to know that
yeah it's nice to know that everyone is
lowing the bar um not just us so that
feels good yeah
I like your TMT sweatshirt thank you
it's like such a cute sweatshirt I've
been wearing so much March recently and
it's just all so cute it's the only way
to live merch I'm sorry like
shopmorningtoast.com
also shopchanel.com if the first one
crashes yeah right we have a backup site
um shop and then there's also shop
airmaze.com that's spelled h-e-r-m-e-s
Hermes
um can we dive into one burden
yourselves no what's that
unburdened yourselves yes
it's like that Drake meme I'm burning
yourselves
no I'm burning yourselves
um unburden yourselves is brought to you
by seed it turns out everything you
think you know about probiotics might be
wrong
you know I did think that probiotic
tortilla chips might have been too good
to be true
the good news is that see are you
laughing at me
yes yes it's funny right really
funny
good news is that seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is the real deal what is the
daily symbiotic it is a broad spectrum
two in one probiotic and Prebiotic it's
a 24 strain broad spectrum probiotic and
Prebiotic formulated for Digestive gut
immune and additional systemic benefits
it's a capsule in capsule and it
protects against stomach acid digestive
enzymes bile salts and viability through
digestion basically the live probiotics
will actually make it to the end of the
small intestine for delivery into the
colon so if you've taken a probiotic
before and you don't feel a difference
it's likely because the good bacteria
wasn't surviving in your GI tract seed
is designed differently and that's why
it works it supports the benefits in and
Beyond the gut it'll support the ease of
bloating Health irregularity ease of
evacuation you know take big dumps is
what they're trying to say but it'll
also support your gut barrier your skin
Health your heart health and your
micronutrient synthesis
if you want to start a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to resume 20 off your first month
of the seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
seed.com toast use code toast all right
so unburden yourselves at the beginning
of every week you write into us tell us
something mortifying that you did or
that happened to you and we are going to
make you feel better about it we're
gonna unburden yourself
so we've got two today and the first one
is perhaps my favorite one
hello Jackson Claude how you doing
mcclord mcclord
the literally most literally the literal
most awkward situation happened to me
yesterday and I simply must unburden
myself I'm a high school teacher and
yesterday after I decided to stay a
little later to get some greeting done I
needed to pee there's a student restroom
literally three steps outside of my
classroom and my room is in the back in
a kind of secluded hallway so I normally
just use that restroom instead of having
to walk all the way around to the
Teacher bathroom
well that was a mistake because while I
was in the stall yesterday two students
came in one started belting out singing
Justin Bieber songs like she was
literally on Broadway and it was pretty
funny at first because the girls
obviously didn't realize I was in there
but then they got really quiet and I
realized they had started making out
I was literally Frozen because I didn't
want to come out of the stall and
embarrass them but I also didn't want to
keep just sitting there listening to
their kissing noises that's weird so I
tried to like make noise by getting
toilet paper clearing my throat but they
just kept on then they started giggling
and whispering to each other no stop and
I love you so much and no I love you so
much and then one of them said no don't
start crying it's okay and then more
kissing
at this point I could not come out of
the stall because they would think I was
either pooping or eavesdropping on them
the entire time so I just had to sit
there and listen to it all until they
finally left it was so awkward and I
wanted to die sincerely never using the
student restroom ever again that is so
awkward
I did at least like at least nothing
happened like yeah you made it out alive
you just had to sit through an
uncomfortable situation but nobody knows
I forgot so I don't know if I ever
realized that teachers and students use
different bathrooms
today in our school
I don't see the teacher in the bathroom
I don't actually know if that's true
because I'm thinking of like think of
the third floor in our school like where
was the teacher's bathroom the student
the the teacher Lounge was there yeah so
where was this was there a bathroom in
there
but like there should be separate
bathrooms yeah it makes sense there
should be set for bathrooms
but this girl obviously is you know
using convenience oh no no I understand
why she's the kid's bathroom
um that is just like so
crazy so they knew someone was in there
the whole time because she started
making she started making noise though
or they just but they were kissing they
didn't hear
they were lost in each other
like I want to die for you because like
you had to listen to like some minors
like making out and like you're their
teacher and it's like definitely
inappropriate but like nobody knows
you're not gonna get in trouble you
didn't have to face them so like it's
fine you could totally on this burden
yeah you can earn the burden but now I'm
just like thinking about
bathroom configuration bathroom
Logistics
uh and especially in a men's room like
urinals like you can't be peeing like
that next to your teacher you can't be
peeing like that next to your student
right that's the same thing yeah
mixy things don't know from the comments
yeah and I'm fairly certain our school
did not have separate bathrooms maybe
they do now why now like what's why
would they have separate problems like
just like things change I don't know
like it's been 10 years since we've been
in school
the teachers and the students are being
in the same place or they're not for I
actually feel like maybe there was like
a single stall like family restroom Vibe
like between do you know the third like
you know
like across from the elevators it was
like the nurse's office and the
teacher's lounge
and then to the right was like the men
and women's right yeah
I feel like there was a single stall in
between the men and women's room and
there was a single stall in the nurse's
office maybe that was what the teachers
used yeah
makes me think definitely
definitely I'm thinking
things are being thought
all right next up hello Jax Claude
roldini brass and stress he doesn't come
to work it with Mom anymore it's so
hurtful
um
with Mommy he said I'm good
okay
Mega toaster here with a major burden
that must be owned this weekend I went
home with a guy who I know decently well
he's a friend of a friend we've hooked
up before we don't really chat or
anything like that I'm a modern woman
I'm in my mid-20s I have a sex positive
attitude and there's no shame in my game
but as we were getting into the ACT I
started hearing a familiar voice saying
hello hello that's when I not so quickly
realized that I had accidentally
answered a phone call from my mother on
my Apple watch
while twisting around in the sheets she
was checking in and I got her off the
phone pretty quickly yes she was on
speakerphone through my Apple watch like
a [ __ ] special agent but now I fear I
can never speak to her again PS I don't
typically wear my Apple watch out at
night but I had a busy evening right
after work so I mindlessly forgot to
take it off never again love and kisses
this is just further proof that nobody
needs an Apple Watch yeah
yeah I know you're very anti-apple
watches yeah I think well first of all
they're ugly so if you want to wear them
to like work or like to work out like I
understand but like get a speedometer
get a pedometer ring like yeah like I
think Apple watches are for honestly the
great unwashed wow and now you have
another reason
to not get one or wear one it's the only
time in my life I've ever seen a useful
benefit of an Apple Watch was when I saw
someone boarding a plane and they had
the Apple watch as their boarding pass
like that was pretty sick I think
there's also like some other interesting
things but I'd have never had one and
I've never like wanted one I count my
steps with my order ring
deuces
um I don't think your mom probably knew
what she was listening to in the first
couple seconds unless you were like oh
yeah baby [ __ ] me good like but you she
didn't say that she said that so I think
so if you're into dirty talk like you
might have an issue but if not your mom
maybe thought you were working out yeah
and as you've stated like you have a sex
positive attitude there's no shame in
your game so if your mom like figured
out what she was hearing then you'll
just be like yeah Mom that's what I did
yeah and hopefully you inherited that
you know Fearless confident women energy
from your mom so
it's really it's her to blame so ladies
you can on these burdens and um
this week was mild I'm so glad nobody's
really going through anything that like
would put us in a pickle yeah not to
make it about us yeah no never
I know that you are not feeling well so
I will let you go it's okay I think I
sweat through my whole track suit so
that's good thank you for showing up for
the toasters when nobody else would so
you're the best love you guys and thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know everybody the Friday on
YouTube's ever watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribing give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available podcast somewhere podcast we
found so on Spotify iTunes Central
Public Radio everybodycast password
hope you have an amazing Tuesday and
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day
goodbye bye